>> Water scarcity is one of the biggest challenges
facing the world
today.
I work for a big brewer, SABMiller, and this
morning we have a session
with lots of large businesses, with NGOs,
and with government ministers
from different departments to talk about how
water unpins economic
growth.
And it's important that all businesses challenge
themselves to become
much more water efficient.
We have a stretching target to improve our
water efficiency by 25
percent by 2015.
But we need to go much further.
And that's why we are working with partners
like WWF, who were there in
the session this morning, to protect watersheds
that communities depend
on, businesses depend on, and farmers depend
on.
And it's still a big challenge.
Water scarcity will be a big challenge.
By 2030, we'll have a demand/supply gap of
about 40 percent.
And we must work together to be water smart
to make sure that doesn't
effect development and it doesn't effect growth.